LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
JOHN MULANEY!
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT IS AMAZING TO BE HERE HOSTING
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" FOR THE
FIFTH TIME.
I THANK YOU.
FOR MANY, MANY REASONS, I'M
GRATEFUL TO BE HERE TONIGHT.
AFTER A VERY COMPLICATED YEAR,
IT IS WONDERFUL TO BE IN
A PLACE THAT HAS ALWAYS
EMPHASIZED SOBRIETY AND MENTAL
HEALTH.
SINCE I LAST HOSTED, DIFFERENT
THINGS HAVE HAPPENED.
I -- IN DECEMBER OF 2020, I WENT
TO DINNER AT A FRIEND'S
APARTMENT.
BUT IT WAS NOT DINNER.
IT WAS AN INTERVENTION.
FOR ME.
MY LEAST FAVORITE KIND OF
INTERVENTION.
WHEN I WALKED IN TO MY
INTERVENTION, I KNEW RIGHT AWAY
THAT IT WAS AN INTERVENTION.
DO YOU KNOW HOW BAD OF A DRUG
PROBLEM YOU HAVE TO HAVE IF WHEN
YOU OPEN A DOOR AND SEE PEOPLE
GATHERED, YOUR FIRST THOUGHT IS,
"THIS IS PROBABLY AN
INTERVENTION ABOUT MY DRUG
PROBLEM"?
THERE IS NO OTHER REASON PEOPLE
WOULD BE BEHIND A DOOR.
I WALK IN.
THERE WERE SIX OF MY FRIENDS IN
NEW YORK IN PERSON AND SIX OF
MY FRIENDS OVER ZOOM FROM L.A.
AND I KNOW YOU MIGHT BE
THINKING, "HEY, IF THAT WAS ME,
I WOULD'VE BEEN LIKE, "IF YOU'RE
SO WORRIED ABOUT ME, HOW COME
YOU DIDN'T FLY IN?"
DON'T WORRY.
I SAID THAT SEVERAL TIMES.
I RANG THAT BELL AS OFTEN AS
POSSIBLE.
I WENT AWAY TO A REHAB, WHICH
WAS A VERY GOOD EXPERIENCE.
I'M VERY GRATEFUL THAT I WENT.
I WAS THERE FOR TWO MONTHS FROM
DECEMBER TO FEBRUARY 2020.
I WAS THERE DURING JANUARY 6th,
THE INTERCEPTION.
WOULDN'T HAVE HAPPENED ON MY
WATCH.
BECAUSE I WOULD HAVE SEEN TO
IT.
WAS THERE EVER AN INSURRECTION
BEFORE I WENT TO REHAB?
NO.
HAS THERE BEEN ONE SINCE I GOT
OUT?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THEY WOULDN'T DARE.
THEY KNOW BABY JAY IS BACK ON
THE STREETS.
LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT ONE THING
YOU DO IN REHAB, OKAY?
YOU SIT DOWN WITH A COUNSELOR
AND YOU GO THROUGH YOUR CELL
PHONE AND YOU DELETE AND BLOCK
ANY DRUG DEALER'S NUMBERS, OKAY?
IN SOME CASES, YOU REACH OUT TO
DEALERS AND YOU SAY, "PLEASE
NEVER CONTACT WITH ME AGAIN."
IT'S CALLED "BREAKING UP WITH
YOUR DRUG DEALER."
SO I DID THIS ONE AFTERNOON.
I SAT DOWN WITH A COUNSELOR.
I TEXTED MY MAIN DEALER ARVIN
FIRST.
I SHOULDN'T HAVE SAID HIS NAME.
THAT'S OKAY.
YOU DON'T KNOW HIM.
SO I TEXT ARVIN, AND I SAY,
"HEY, IT'S ME.
I'M DELETING AND BLOCKING YOU.
I'M NEVER GOING TO BUY DRUGS
FROM YOU AGAIN.
I'M SOBER NOW."
AND THEN I'M REALLY POLITE, SO I
DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO END THE TEXT.
SO I WAS LIKE, "BUT THANK YOU
FOR ALL OF THE NIGHTS THAT
BECAME DAYS AND YOUR INSPIRED
PROFESSIONALISM."
.
I SEND THE TEXT, ALL RIGHT?
BEFORE I CAN DELETE AND BLOCK
HIM, HE TEXTS ME BACK.
HE GOES, "HEY, I'M SO PROUD OF
YOU.
I'M SO HAPPY YOU GOT SOBER."
YOU KNOW, I
ONLY BOUGHT DRUGS TO SELL TO YOU
BECAUSE I WAS WORRIED ABOUT YOU
AND I DIDN'T WANT YOU TO GET
WORSE STUFF OFF THE STREET."
I KNOW!
AND I'M BREAKING UP WITH THIS
GUY?
SO I CAN'T BLOCK HIM NOW.
I TEXT HIM BACK, YOU KNOW?
AND I GO, "OH, MY GOD.
YOU SWEET MAN."
I SAID, "YOU ONLY BOUGHT
DRUGS TO SELL TO ME?"
HE SAYS "YEAH."
I SAID, "DID YOU SELL DRUGS TO
OTHER PEOPLE?"
HE SAID "NO."
I SAID, "THIS IS A WEIRD TIME TO
ASK.
BUT ARE YOU A DRUG DEALER?"
HE SAID, "NO.
I'M A PAINTER.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS."
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, I HAVE NO
IDEA HOW I KNOW THIS PERSON.
SO I TEXT HIM.
I GO, "HOW DID IT COME TO BE
THAT YOU SELL ME DRUGS?"
AND HE WROTE BACK, "I DON'T
KNOW.
YOU JUST KEPT ASKING."
I LIKE THAT STORY BECAUSE THERE
ARE MANY TALES OF DRUG DEALERS
WHO HAVE TURNED INNOCENT PEOPLE
INTO DRUG ADDICTS.
I MIGHT BE THE FIRST DRUG ADDICT
TO TURN AN INNOCENT MAN INTO A
DRUG DEALER.
LIFE IS A LOT BETTER AND HAPPIER
NOW.
I HAVE A 12-WEEK-OLD SON.
I'M VERY EXCITED.
YES.
HE'S A PRETTY COOL GUY FOR
SOMEONE WHO CAN'T VOTE.
HE HAS -- HIS LEGS ARE LIKE
LITTLE CALZONES, AND I WANT TO
EAT THEM.
LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT
THE MOMENT I FIRST BONDED THE
HARDEST WITH MY -- WITH MY SON.
HIS NAME IS MALCOLM.
WE'RE IN THE DELIVERY ROOM.
MY GIRLFRIEND GIVES BIRTH TO
HIM.
AND HE'S CRYING A LITTLE.
AND THEY BRING HIM OVER TO THIS
WARMER.
AND THEY PUT HIM UNDER
THIS WARMER, UNDER THIS REALLY
BRIGHT LIGHT THAT'S SHINING IN
HIS FACE.
AND MALCOLM, HE'S LAYING THERE,
AND THIS LIGHT IS RIGHT IN HIS
EYES.
AND -- AND MALCOLM, HE DOESN'T
CRY OR DO ANYTHING, HE JUST
LOOKS AND HE GOES -- HE WAS
ANNOYED, BUT HE DIDN'T SAY
ANYTHING.
AND I WAS LIKE, "THAT'S MY SON."
A POLITE MAN IN AN UNCOMFORTABLE
SITUATION, BUT HE'S NOT
GOING TO MAKE A FUSS.
AND IT WAS A SUPER BRIGHT LIGHT.
HE'D NEVER SEEN ANY LIGHT IN HIS
LIFE.
LIKE -- AND I'VE SEEN MANY AND I
WAS LIKE, "THAT'S A BRIGHT
LIGHT."
IT'S FUNNY -- IT'S FUNNY TO SEE
ON A BABY'S FACE THE
EXPRESSION -- JESUS WITH THE
LIGHTS.
MALCOLM IS A VERY GOOD BABY, BUT
HIS FAVORITE PASSIFIER JUST GOT
RECALLED, THOUGH.
IT'S SUCH A BUMMER.
HE LOVED IT.
SO WE HAVE A DOZEN OF THEM.
WE STILL HAVE THEM ON A BASKET
ON THE COUNTER.
AND I CAN SEE THIS LOOK IN HIS
EYES, ALWAYS LIKE, "OH, I WANT
TO USE THOSE, BUT I CAN'T
BECAUSE THEY COULD KILL ME."
I'M LIKE, "WELCOME TO MY WORLD,
HOMIE."
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, WE HAVE A
GREAT SHOW.